all right so in this module we're going
to be talking about semantics so we've
started talking about syntax and in
propositional logic and then we defined
formulas for positional formulas which
basically take propositional symbols and
logical connectives and put them
together and symbolically create
something that we call a formula and
that was kind of a syntactic view of
things where we didn't assign any
meanings there was no meanings for
anything it was just symbols and what we
would like to do in this module is we're
trying to assign meanings to those
syntactical formulas that we defined and
then that corresponds to semantics so in
this in this module we're going to be
talking about semantics and giving
meanings to those formulas and in
general in this lecture we're going to
have a good number of definitions so i'm
going to write out those definitions in
a separate whiteboard so we can keep
track of them but a good number of
definitions are coming up especially in
this module and and let's start with
some of them so so the first definition
is is a definition of a model and this
is a very poor choice of words you've
been using the word model throughout uh
the the lectures of this class as a
different as a different thing right
like we talked about modeling inference
and learning but in the logic lecture
we're going to assign a different
meaning to the word model and that has
historical reasons because historically
like model has been used in these
settings uh for for for in in logic in
in this particular way to to refer to
assignments really so so a model for
this lecture and for the logic lecture
let's refer to a model in propositional
logic as an assignment of truth values
to propositional symbols
so i'm going to use the word w for a
model w for world so so that's why it's
it's called w so a model of w in
propositional logic is just an
assignment of truth values okay so what
does that mean so let's look at an
example for example let's say we have
three propositional symbols a b and c
okay how many models do we have well we
can have eight possible models right two
to the three possible models or worlds
that we can live in and a particular w a
particular model is going to be a
particular assignment so for example i
can pick a equal to zero b equal to one
and c equal to zero and that's a model
that is one w that corresponds to an
assignment of truth values to
prepositional symbols okay so let me
write that on our uh on our whiteboard
here so going back here
i'm going to start
under semantics
and then we have the word model
model
and i'm going to use the word w for it
okay
all right
let's go back
all right so now we are ready to define
this thing that's called interpretation
function and an interpretation function
is the thing that actually gives us
gives us semantics and gives us meaning
so what is an interpretation function so
let f be a formula that's what we
defined in syntax and let w be a model
okay
so an assignment so an interpretation
function i gets a formula gets a model
and it basically outputs true or false
it basically tells us if if w satisfies
f or if w doesn't satisfy f okay so so
interpretation function is really the
thing that binds formulas and models
formulas living in the syntactic
syntactic land and models living in the
semantic land and and basically
interpretation function is trying to
like connect them and tell us if that is
true or not so so let me go back here
and let me let me write out
interpretation function
enter
rotation function
so it's a function i
that takes f a formula and w and it
gives us true or false so let me go
here and show this so let's say that we
have a formula f i'm gonna write our or
draw our formulas using these rectangle
rectangles so uh in the in the syntactic
land you might have a number of formulas
let's say i have one formula f and in
the world of semantics we might have
different models right these are
different models or worlds that we can
live in or worlds
and i can pick a specific one let me
call that w no
okay let me call that w
and and what i can do is i can basically
connect the formula to this w using this
interpretation function so i'm going to
interpret have an interpretation
function f and w
that gives me true or false if if f
satisfies w or not okay i can have other
w's in this space of models in this
semantic line so how do we define an
interpretation function so
um the way we define an interpretation
function is recursively in a similar way
that we defined our syntax so we're
going to start with propositional
symbols so so we have these
propositional symbols a b and c right
like these these take boolean values and
the interpretation function of each one
of these each one of these propositional
symbols p
and a model w is just going to return w
of that prepositional prepositional
symbol okay remember w is an assignment
to these so going back here let me let
me give you an example so my w is going
to be an assignment that maybe says um a
it takes the value zero okay
and my prepositional symbol is just a
right so if i look at interpretation
function over p and w it's basically
checking
in interpreting a
and
the model a being assigned to equal to
zero and that returns the value zero
okay so so that is just for the for the
base case of this okay
so then when we think about more general
formulas these formulas how are they how
are they defined they're defined based
on these logical connectives used
applied over prepositional symbols and
based on that we can we can basically
recursively define this interpretation
function so i can have a formula f and a
formula g and i can create kind of this
truth table and an interpretation
function of f and w could take value
zero or one interpretation function of g
and w could take value zero or one and
then for anything else like for any of
these other logical connectives i can
basically recursively define them so
what would be an interpretation function
of negation of f and w it would
basically try to negate this column
right so so it would be one one zero
zero or if i'm thinking about
interpretation of f and the g well what
would that be
and and and the model w what would that
be that would be interpretation function
of f and w and interpretation of g and w
so basically adding these two columns
and that gives us these values and so on
similarly we can define interpretation
function over f or g or f implying g or
if bi-directional implication of g and
and so on and then we can kind of assign
meanings to these more more generic
formulas okay
all right so so let's look at an example
of how do we do this recursively so
let's say we have a formula f and that
formula is negation of a and b and
bi-directional implications c okay so
that's my formula i have an assignment i
have i have a model that model is truth
assignment to my prepositional symbols a
b and c so let's say a is one b is one
and c is equal to 0 and now i can call
an interpretation function f and w and
see what the value of that would be
how do we do that well let's start with
these notes so um at this node i can
call interpretation function over symbol
a and w what is that equal to well that
is equal to just one because i'm just
going to call my my table of models
right i already have this that's just
equal to one
then negation of a is going to be equal
to zero what is interpretation function
of b and w well again i have an
assignment i have a model that tells me
b takes value one so that's one
and then if i'm taking an interpretation
function of negation of a and b then
that is an interval the the end of these
these two so one and zero gives me zero
similarly i can look at interpretation
function of c and w reading that off my
model that is equal to zero and then
when i'm looking at equivalence of this
c and negation of a and b well these two
are equivalent so that's just going to
be equal to one okay so this is just
showing recursively how do we how do we
run an interpretation function see
there's like there's no learning here
this is like defined by logic right like
you can define your own logic that would
be fun but but this is defined by some
sort of logic that is this propositional
logic that we have defined using using
our formulas and using using our
connectives and so on and i'm just like
calling this like i'm just computing
this i'm not doing anything like fancy
here okay
all right so um so each formula and
model right like we'll give like we can
interpret it using this interpretation
function and that gives us a value zero
or one okay so so now i'm going to
define this thing that's called models
of f and basically it's a set of w's
it's a set of models where
interpretation function is equal to one
so going back here right like looking at
this this this there could be one w and
i can check interpretation function of f
and w i can also be looking at a set of
models right and i can call this models
of f
and what is models of f right models of
f is a setting where interpretation is
it's a set of w's so let me write that
here models of f what is that equal to
it's a set it's a set of w's such that
interpretation function of f and w
is going to be equal to 1.
so let me write that in the set of my
definitions so we talked about
interpretation function we talked about
a single model
and
i don't know why this does this let me
erase this
we have models
m of f
okay and what is that that is a set of
w's such that interpretation function of
f and w
is just equal to one
okay
all right so now we have our models
let's go back here
okay
all right so so basically um intuitively
you can think of this models of f as all
the all the worlds all the assignments
were f holds and anything outside of
this is still like has some world has
some possibility but that's a setting
where this particular f doesn't doesn't
necessarily hold okay
so so let's look at an example let's say
our formula f is rain or red okay
so then if i think about models all
possible models are when we think about
rain taking values zero or one and with
taking value 0 1 so i can kind of like
show that by this 2x2 grid that's all
possible models but what is models of f
models of f is when rain or red holds
and that is the shaded area right so the
shaded area here is showing kind of like
the meaning of this formula f which is
again symbolically written doesn't have
a meaning but models of f is assigning a
meaning to it so it's saying hey these
grids is showing like what is the
meaning of rain or wet okay
and and the key idea here in logic in
general is there's this formula although
it is written like again syntactically
and then it is it is a symbolic
representation it's a very compact like
representation of a giant set of models
right so so in general the nice thing
about logic is is we could use formulas
to compactly represent like very like
large meanings like a lot of times like
exponential meanings could be
represented by by formulas that are
pretty compact and nice and then that is
kind of the power of logic you can write
this compactly and then you can do
operations on it you can do inference on
it and so on and that that is really
nice okay
all right so that was formulas and
models and interpretation functions
finding formulas and models
and and what now we want to do is we
want to think about how could we do
operations here and how could we what
would what would meanings like what
would new formulas add in terms of
meanings to the knowledge that we
already have so for that let's define
something that's called a knowledge base
so a knowledge base is a set of formulas
that i already know okay so if i have
like a system a virtual assistant system
that that i want to i want to add logic
to it or i want to speak to it using
using language or using logic
that that system has a knowledge base
which is a set of formulas that are
already represented it's a conjunction
or intersection of a bunch of things
that it already knows okay so let me go
back here and write out knowledge base
as a thing
so
knowledge
space
kb i'm going to use kb for this and this
is a set of formulas that that you
already know okay so we might already
know um a formula that says rain or snow
or we might already know there's traffic
okay so this is our knowledge base okay
so then what happens is is that someone
might come and give me a new formula and
what we're interested in looking at is
how does how does that affect our
knowledge
so before getting in there so so
knowledge base is a set of formulas so
it is in the syntax land
what would be the analog of it in the
semantics land it would be models of kb
and and what is the models of kb models
of kb is going to be an intersection of
models of f
okay so maybe let's go back here let me
let me just look at an example so we
looked at an example where
let's say i have a formula f1 and if one
says it's raining and snowing
okay
and maybe i have f2 and f2 says there is
traffic
okay
let me let me separate these okay
and and i have a knowledge base and my
knowledge base has f1
and f2 in it okay so someone already
told me there's raining and snowing and
then there's traffic so what would be
models of kb so models of kb
is is going to be an intersection of
models of f1
with models of f2
and and why is that because if you think
about it right like
f1 is a formula
f1 has a set of models corresponding to
it models of f1 corresponding to it
and f2 is another formula that i'm just
adding to my knowledge base
and that has a bunch of other
models corresponding to it
and my knowledge base right like is now
going to be an intersection
of these two because as we add more
formulas right as we add more knowledge
to our knowledge base then then our
models is going to become smaller and
smaller because we are adding more
constraints which is pretty interesting
right so in general if i have let me
maybe write that in a different color so
if i have a knowledge base
and i add a new formula to that
knowledge base maybe maybe i union it
with a new formula that is added new f
what would be the effect of that on
models of kb
the effect of data models of kb is going
to be what i had for models of kb
intersection models of f
so adding new formulas is constraining
our models right constraining the
meaning more and more because it can be
like if you have raining and snowing and
you have traffic as a whole other set of
models the intersection of the two is
going to give me give me um this this
this models okay
so um also let me connect this so this
corresponds to these models correspond
to these mods
all right
so let's go back here
so so that's how we define models of
knowledge base let's look at another
example here so let's say we're looking
at raining as one formula
models of rain is going to be this
shaded area rain is equal to one and
then we have another formula rain
implies wet and what is models of rain
implies wet it is uh basically negation
of rain or red so basically it is this
shaded area
if i'm looking at a knowledge base that
has both of these in it
then what would be the models of that
knowledge base is just going to be the
intersection of these two shaded area
which is basically this square okay
where we have both rain and rain implies
vent folding
all right sounds good
and then this is what i've already
basically mentioned we have knowledge
base if we add a formula to it we
increase the size of our knowledge base
we're shrinking the the size of set of
models because we're constraining things
more and more so we are constraining the
meaning part
all right so so now let's talk about
this idea of what happens if i have a
knowledge base and i add a new formula
so i have a knowledge base i'm trying to
add a new formula see what happens and
there are three things that can happen
so so one option is entailment so what
entailment says is if i have a knowledge
base if i have kb as my knowledge base
and you come and tell me a new formula f
and that formula is not adding anything
to my knowledge base then then we say we
have entailment okay so so this is a
scenario where f is just not adding any
information or any new constraints like
this is basically telling me things are
already new okay so so we say kb entails
f and what that
that is written using this double line
kind of um
symbol so if you say kb entails f if and
only if models of kb is an intersection
of models of f
let's look at an example here so let's
go back to
uh let's go back here maybe i'll start a
new
so we have three options
one is called entailment
entailment
so let's start with a knowledge base
and my knowledge base maybe is rain and
snow so i have a formula in my knowledge
base that says rain and snow
and that has models corresponding to it
so this is models of kb
and you might come and tell me a new
formula and that new formula is rain
and if you tell me rain and i already
have rain and snow in my knowledge base
that doesn't add any knowledge to me
right like i already knew it was raining
so so then um this models is going to be
as super models of f
is going to be a super set of models of
kb
okay so we say kb
entails f
if and only if
models of kb
is an intersection
of models of f
so
didn't didn't tell me anything new
already knew that and and that is
entailment so let me go back here and
maybe add these um
under
our definition so now we have defined
entailment
contracts okay
all right
so let's go back here
so rain and snow is entailing stem
so
okay so that was one option another
option is contradiction so so what is
contradiction contradiction is a
scenario where you're telling me a new
formula f i already have a knowledge
base kb you tell me a new formula f and
that is contradicting with my knowledge
base okay so
the the in in the models land what
happens is that models of kb doesn't
have any intersections with models of f
so f contradicts what we know our
knowledge base if and only if models of
kb intersection models of f is going to
be the empty set
right so so let's look at an example uh
let's maybe go back here so
our second option is contradiction
so let's write that here
contradiction
so contradiction is a scenario where i
know some uh knowledge base
so my knowledge base is maybe
rain and snow again so
so i think it's raining and snowing
and then you come and tell me a new new
formula and that new formula is negation
of snow maybe
okay
and then that contradicts with my
knowledge base right so if that
contradicts with my knowledge base what
happens is that there is a models of kb
and there is a models of f
and they don't have any intersection so
contradiction is a scenario where models
of kb
intersection models of f
is empty
one other interesting thing to to kind
of like notice here
is that if you think about contradiction
contradiction is very related to
entailment
contradiction is the same thing as
entailing negation of f and then why is
that the case because if you look at
models of f right
models of negation of f is anything
outside of it right so if this is models
of negation of f
then what is happening the thing that's
happening is that models of of kb
is a subset of models of negation of f
and and if you remember our definition
of entailment that is the same thing as
kb
entailing negation of f
okay so that's pretty interesting
because contradiction is the same thing
as entailing negation of f
all right so so those were the two cases
so far right you either told me a new
formula and and already knew it so that
is entailment or you tell me a new
formula and that contradicts the
knowledge base that i've had so that is
contradiction okay and let's add that
here
so we talked about entailment
now we've talked about contradiction
and we wrote entailment as kb entailing
a formula and contradiction is kb
entailing negation of a formula okay
all right so there is a third case let's
talk about that third case
let me skip that so we talked about
contradiction being very related to
entailment and kb contradicting with f
is the same thing as kb entailing
negation of f
all right so the third case here is what
we're calling contingency and that is
when you're telling me a formula and
that formula is adding is actually
telling me something i didn't know it's
telling me some non-trivial information
okay so so that is when models of kb has
some intersection with some non-trivial
intersection with models of f okay
so so that is uh when we write models of
kb intersection models of f is is going
to be a subset of models of kb but it's
going to be strict subset of models of
kb if this is equal like we get
entailment so so we don't include uh
equality here okay
all right let's look at an example maybe
um let's go back here
so our third case
is contingency
and that is when i have maybe my
knowledge base and maybe my knowledge
base is just rain this time
and you come and tell me a new formula
and that new formula is no okay so so my
knowledge base thought it is raining so
i have my models of knowledge base
corresponding to raining here and then
you come and tell me hey by the way it
is it is also snowing and models of
snowing is here and there is some
non-trivial intersection going on here
okay so so contingency is when models of
kb
intersection models of f
is going to be a subset and it's not
going to be equal to models of kb
and similarly empty set is going to be a
subset of this but it's not going to be
equal so if you get like some
non-trivial information something that
you didn't know and that gets added
okay so so that is contingency
and going back here let me add
contingency as the third
option
contingency
and contingency um is when you have
these non-trivial intersections i'm not
gonna write it out
all right
let's go back here okay so so we have
these three possibilities you give me a
new formula
i'm either entailing it or contradicting
it or or i have contingency
so now let's talk about let's talk about
how we would use these ideas if we want
to implement a virtual assistant
remember like we started this lecture
thinking about having a virtual
assistant where we can talk to it in
logic or language and that virtual
assistants right like you can tell with
some information or we can ask it
questions and then maybe you want to
implement this tell operation so if i
want to implement a tell operation in
this in this virtual assistant the
spiritual assistant is going to have
some knowledge base at the moment some
kb and i tell it f a new formula f so
what can happen so if i tell it a new
formula maybe i tell it it is raining so
i do tell rain
three things can happen right it can
either it can either entail f right my
knowledge base might already like have
raining in it
in that case the response to tell
operation until tell it is raining it's
going to be i already knew that okay so
so if it says if my virtual assistant
already entails rain it should respond
to me as i already knew that
okay if it contradicts them it should
say i don't believe that because it's
knowledge base basically says it's not
raining and now you're telling it it is
raining and and because of that it would
respond as i don't believe that because
my knowledge base tells me the opposite
or if you're telling it something new
you're telling it it is raining and it
didn't know that or didn't have any
information about it then it should say
i learned something new and based on
that thing that you're telling it it
should update knowledge base it should
update its kb by by this this new
formula that it is raining okay so so
now we can implement a tele operation
based on based on these three ideas of
entailment contingency and contradiction
in a very similar fashion we can also
implement an ask operation if you ask it
is it raining then based on that it can
it can go ahead and it can answer yes a
definite yes if kb already entails f so
if you have entailment it should answer
no if we have a contradiction if kb
contradicts f right or if kb entails
negation of f so it should give us a
definite no no that there's a
contradiction
or it should tell us i don't know if
there is contingency it doesn't know so
if you ask it is it raining it doesn't
know so it should just say i don't know
okay so so going back to the things we
were defining here let me let me move
this inference rule thing
okay
so um let me just write
tell n so so we talked about this till
an ask operation and and we can
basically implement tell and ask based
on this entailment contradiction and
contingency
okay
all right so i want to just do a quick
side note here i don't want to go into
this in too much detail but there is a
connection between the things we were
talking about here and and some of the
topics we discussed like two weeks ago
in bayesian networks right so so we've
been talking about this idea of models
and having having these types of these
types of models and this is the same
thing as assignments right and you can
think of it you can basically think of
having bayesian networks as a
distribution over these assignments over
these models right i can have like a
equal to zero b equal to zero c equal to
zero and i can have a probability
assigned to that like probability of
that could be point three and i can have
another assignment or model and i can
have another probability assigned to it
so from a bayesian network
perspective from probabilistic
perspective one can think about logic in
a probabilistic way and think about
probability of a formula given a
knowledge base so so when you have a
knowledge base you have some knowledge
and and you're asking about a formula
one can think of instead of thinking
about just these three different things
like entailment contradiction and
contingency one can think of a
probability like an actual like value
right and probability of the formula
given a knowledge base so what is that
going to be equal to
that is going to be equal to probability
of of models w's that that exists in the
in the intersection of models of kb and
models of f right over probability of
all possible models in knowledge base so
so w's are all possible models in my
knowledge base i'm going to sum over all
those probabilities of all possible
models in my knowledge base in the
denominator and in the numerator i'm
going to just focus on models that are
in the intersection of models of kb and
models of f and then the union so so
models of kb union f is equal to models
of kb intersection models of f that's
why there's a union here you remember
like if you add an f to your kb you're
shrinking your knowledge base so so
that's why this this numerator is
smaller right you're shrinking you're
shrinking your knowledge base by adding
this f to it okay
and if you think about this fraction
right this is a number this is a number
between zero and one and now we have
probabilities we have actually like a
probability for f like being satisfied
or not given given a knowledge base
but in general like this was just like a
quick diversion like talking about a
probabilistic view of this there's quite
a bit of work actually in logic and
probabilistic versions of it and
thinking about probabilistic model
checking and instead of giving just like
zero one values what would be a
probabilistic view of it we're not gonna
go into details of those in this class
and and basically you can think of these
probabilities as these three different
ways of looking at the problem that we
have been talking about if this
probability is equal to zero then we
basically have an answer of no we have
contradiction right like f is not
satisfied
well if this probability is equal to one
if the numerator and denominator are
equal to each other then you're
answering yes right like f is not adding
any information so we have entailment
and if you get any other value in
between any other value between zero and
one then you're in an entailment
situation sorry we are in a sorry
contingency situation and we basically
say we don't know right like any of them
we basically say we don't know okay
all right so so that was just a quick
kind of like connection to probabilistic
generalization of some of the things we
were talking about on ambition networks
but now let's just go back to go back to
the same problem you're talking about
right so so we've talked about these
three different things entailment
contingency and contradiction we've
talked about how we can have a tell and
ask opera operator based on that now we
are going to talk about this idea of
satisfiability so what is satisfiability
so a knowledge-based kb is satisfiable
if models of kb is not empty okay
very simple like models of kb is not
empty we have satisfied gold okay so why
is satisfiable to useful why am i
talking about this at satisfiability
because satisfiability is a well-known
problem we have really good like solvers
for it sat solvers and then we're going
to talk about that in one slide really
quickly so it's nice to think about
these three different things entailment
um and contingency and and contradiction
in in kind of a view of a problem of
satisfiability okay so so we have these
three things satisfiability gives me a
yes or no answer so how can i use
satisfiability to answer if you are in
either in any of these situations
so so the way you satisfy ability is we
do two calls to satisfy
so
the first call is in general if i want
to think about my ask operator or tell
operator and if i want to reduce it to
satisfiability i can i can do two calls
to satisfy both i can first ask if kb
union negation of f is satisfiable or
not okay so what does the answer to that
give me so if i get no for that right if
kb union negation of f is not
satisfiable i have entailment right so i
get
my answer for entailment here
and if i get yes for that that doesn't
answer everything right like if i just
get yes for this i don't know if i'm in
a contingency situation or a
contradiction situation so what do i
need to do i need to do another call to
satisfy voting and the second call to
satisfyability is asking if kb union f
is satisfiable and what does that check
well well if i get no for that then i'm
getting contradiction remember
contradiction is the same thing as
entailing negation of f that is why the
answer for this gives me contradiction
and if i get yes for that i get
contingency so what i've just done is is
if i in general if i want to know if i'm
in the entailment contradiction or
contingency situation
then i can basically figure that out
with two calls to satisfiability
and and why do i want to know i'm in any
of these situations because that helps
me implement my ask and tell operations
so going back here
so we talked about ask and so we talked
about how it relates to entailment
contradiction and contingency and now we
have talked about satisfiability
as a way of answering
which scenario we are in okay
and then how do we answer satisfiability
so so that's a good question to ask so
what is satisfiability so satisfiability
and checking satisfiable to the sad
problem in propositional logic is
basically just a special case of solving
a constrained satisfaction problem a csv
and we have already like like learned
about cscs and solving csvs so what that
means is we can basically check
satisfiability we can basically uh
check if the csb problem like was the
solution to the csv problem and solve
satisfied we'll give you the algorithms
that we already have access to okay and
this idea of checking satisfiability is
called model checking you're checking if
a model exists or not you're checking if
an assignment exists or not okay so so
the mapping of the sat problem to csvs
is as follows so prepositional symbols
are basically variables what we used to
call variables
formulas are basically constraints and
then if you have variables and
constraints you can come up with an
assignment and that assignment is
basically a model so you're checking if
a model exists or not you're checking if
if a satisfying assignment exists or not
okay
let's look at an example so let's say
our knowledge base has these two
formulas in it we have a or b
and we have b um
bi-directional implication negation of c
okay
all right so we have three symbols a b
and c these symbols are the same things
as csp variables so we can have three
nodes these three variables and then we
have basically two formulas these
formulas create constraints in our csv
so we have a or b and then we have we
have b equivalent negation of c
and then what are we doing so we have a
csv we can solve it right we can find an
assignment a consistent assignment for
it which is the same thing as a
satisfying model and if you find an
assignment this problem is satisfiable
model shaking comes up with a model for
it
and then if it is not satisfiable it's
going to return as unset it doesn't come
up with any assignments
so that's kind of nice going back here
right like this problem that you've been
talking about this tell and ask
operation
reduces to entail my contradiction and
contingency i can use satisfiability to
cause the satisfiability to to answer
that then how do i do that well i use
model checkers to do that so so that's
called model checking checking the
satisfiability which is basically
solving a csv okay
all right so going back here okay so so
what does model checking do model
checking takes as an input a knowledge
base and what does it output it outputs
if there exists a satisfying model or
not and if it does it returns that model
okay so it checks if models of kb is is
not empty
and there are a good number of
algorithms out there that try to do
model checking and and um some of the
older ones is the dpl is kind of like a
well-known algorithm that tries to do
satisfiability and model checking what
it does is it uses backtracking search
and quite a bit of pruning and quite a
bit of heuristic goes into it
to make sure that it can solve this
problem as fast as possible um some some
more recent algorithms are things like
walk sets that is pretty similar to
gibbs sampling and it does a randomized
local search there are a good number of
solvers out there satisfiability solvers
out there z3 is a famous
sat solver that you can look into if
you're interested in solving sad
problems
and and with that we now have a good
idea of syntax we have a good idea of
semantics and next what we would like to
talk about is we would like to talk
about what the formulas get us right
like why do we live in the formula on
land like why do we want to even like
look at syntax and it turns out that we
can we can do inference on formulas and
and that that buys us quite a bit so in
the next module we're going to be
talking about what formula is formulas
bias and how to do inference rules
you